i legit never thought this day would
come yet here we are about to review
Dragon Ball GT while I have made Dragon
Ball GT something of a running joke over
the last while as a bit of light-hearted
fun there has always been an element of
truth to it when the original series
ended way back when I was a kid like
many others my age I quickly shipped to
Dragon Ball GT thinking it will be more
of what I loved about Dragon Ball Z and
at the time it wasn't I say at the time
because right now I want to review this
show as fairly as I possibly can I
haven't seen Dragon Ball GT in maybe 15
years and I have changed considerably
since then the strong but negative
feelings I had for Dragon Ball GT have
much like its relevance in the modern
Dragon Ball anime landscape faded with
time and at present I don't really
recall much of the story and my feelings
towards that are about as neutral as
they ever have been so what better time
to dive headfirst into the show that
ended it all for me when I was a young
teenager a show that pushed me away
frustrated me beyond belief and
admittedly moved me to tears this is my
review of the infamous and intensely
controversial Dragon Ball GT part 1 the
black star Dragon Balls
Dragon Ball GT isn't really divided into
clean sections like Dragon Ball super
was so I've decided to follow the arcs
as they are defined in the fandom the
first arc being the Black Star Dragon
Ball saga that flows from episodes 1
through 216 I want to make something
clear here from the get-go having just
finished watching these it's not gonna
be pretty so if you're a fan of this arc
I'll try to be fair and explain where my
issues are and why so without further
ado let's get into it story itself kicks
off as Goku finishes up his training
with uber and then sends him on his way
I guess the ending of Dragon Ball Z
wasn't worth following up on and wasn't
worth exploring right now this honestly
doesn't bother me too much but really
reinforces the notion that Goku's
decision to go off for a decade training
herb was a bit of a waste of time or at
least this is the message the show is
sending us right now a little bit later
the pilaf gang make it to the lookout
somehow and discover the black star
Dragon Balls you know just sitting there
out in the open
you know the dragon balls that have
earth-shattering ramifications if used
the dragon itself when summoned is
probably the most visually impressive
spectacle from this arc however Goku
interrupts peel off as he kind of sort
of wishes Goku was a kid again I mean he
sort of says it but not really I'm not
really sure what counts as a wish
anymore but we gotta get the plot moving
somehow I guess and sure is a good thing
that Goku's closed became a kid with him
- once pilaf finishes using these balls
to turn Goku into a little kid again the
balls then dispersed throughout the
universe and that's when we hear that
the earth will be destroyed in exactly
one year from when the wish was made if
the balls are not gathered again now
this is where the show loses me even
more I have no earthly idea how these
balls really work I mean I would assume
like the other Dragon Balls they would
have turned to stone along with the
other balls once the old Guardian had
passed also why would their creator have
made them to scatter across the universe
how would he the creator of these Dragon
Balls have been able to gather them see
cuz there was no other way to get off of
earth at the time also I have no idea
why there's a 1-year time limit and a
consequence of not meeting that time
limit - it seems really arbitrary only
there to provide incentive for Goku who
up until this bombshell hits was rather
indifferent to being young again or to
even collect the Dragon Balls again in
the first place I
the dragonballs in this show are a
MacGuffin used to make the story work
but they didn't need to be dragonballs
in this instance they're already
different enough to warrant being their
own thing tying them to objects within a
show that has already so many rules to
abide by makes things needlessly
difficult to work with that said the
rest of the episode is spent
reintroducing old characters that we
won't see for the rest of the arc and
most importantly the character of Penn
someone we will be spending a lot of
time with episode 2 is the first episode
where we will see the pace the series
will be moving at glacial pace there's
no sense of urgency and the decisions
that are made seem excessively juvenile
Goku says that they should use the
regular Earth's Dragon Balls to relocate
themselves to the Dragon Balls in space
but I say that's pretty dumb why not
just wish them to earth did I just make
the entire act pointless the vast
majority of this episode covers very
filler centric stuff like Goku getting
kidnapped and pouting over not being
left go and trunks goofing off of work
additionally no one seems to be taking
this thing with the balls seriously
other than Gohan chichi and Bulma in
reality the most capable people should
go on this life-threatening trip not the
children as a form of discipline also
Vegeta has a mustache I just needed to
say that pan then sneaks out onto the
ship before blasting off and is now part
of the party Goku trunks and pan blast
off into space at this point in my watch
through I really like that pan had a
reason for leaving to prove her maturity
and independence and in addition to this
motivation has a strong personality it's
not exactly a unique character type or
unique personality but she fills the
role well of an immature kid trying to
be strong like her relatives I'm gonna
try to go through the episodes faster
now because they get really bad episode
3 begins and they land on a mega and all
of a sudden it feels like star wars this
subplot seems to be ignoring the Dragon
Balls that they literally just left to
retrieve almost immediately after
leaving Earth in order to deal with this
planet that shakes people down for money
we then get introduced to kill a little
robot that now acts as the group's
dragon radar episode 4 begins and yes
there is a part two to this story and
trust me I've already glazed over a ton
of stuff that really has no consequence
within the story their ship gets
confiscated and they need to retrieve it
from this weird alien dictator guy Goku
can use Instant Transmission because
plot needs to happen and some random guy
with
big ears appears and knows that Goku is
a Saiyan somehow based exclusively on
his kamehameha an earth learned
technique and yes now two episodes deep
into this godforsaken subplot they are
still on this damn planet and there's
more by the time the third episode in
this mini R comes around I noticed that
an absurd amount of time has been spent
not gathering the Dragon Balls you know
the balls that if you don't gather them
will bring about the Earth's destruction
somehow reg if the big eared alien guy
that recognized go who was the saying
begins to fight Goku it's a really short
fight but honestly it's fine it's
definitely the best part of the show so
far but was only like two minutes long I
didn't really care about the fight I
don't care about red jib but it was
better than looking at like 95% of what
the show has put in front of me so far
but issue with this mini arc within this
saga I'm watching can be summed up in
one word pointless the last three
episodes could be removed entirely and
the only thing that will be lost is the
little robot guy and he could have been
introduced or incorporated into the
story in a bunch of other ways we didn't
learn anything new about pan or trunks
or Goku from this story's inclusion six
episodes deep and we're finally close to
the first Dragon Ball and it's the worst
one so far they'll end this planet where
everything is like Earth except giant
pangas taken by a bunch of bees for most
of the episode and a giant accidentally
takes the Dragon Ball and lodges it in
its tooth pan gets rescued and Goku
retrieves the ball by being the Giants
dentist none of this is important the
only thing you need to know is that they
have one Dragon Ball now next the next
two episodes yes two are spent within on
mini Ark again fun the story itself
revolves around this village that are
seemingly being tormented by this fat
ugly annoying catfish monster a monster
that claims to cause earthquakes in
order to not anger the Beast and to
solve the problem the gang decides of
the best course of action is to dress
trunks like a girl and to offer him as a
bride to the monster it turns out that
the Beast cannot cause earthquakes but
can only sense when they are going to
happen which makes no sense considering
the perfect timing the earthquakes have
in this story shown up but let's ignore
that they beat him up they stop a
volcano or something and just as the
Dragon Ball is about to be handed over
out of nowhere some blue guy in a red
unitard steals the sec
dragonball they spent two agonizingly
slow episodes retrieving i feel cheated
there is so much useless motion in this
series but however i spoke too soon
what follows this is the main plot of
the arc and it's probably the worst
anime anything I've ever seen
I'm going to try my best at describing
what happens and why I have a problem
with it I cannot promise I won't get
angry they begin chasing after the Uni
targets that stole the Dragonball until
they get lost in a big worm boulder
don't ask
turns out a large group of bad guys are
looking for the Dragon Balls across the
universe without any means of tracking
them down no less first of all how do
they know the Dragon Balls were out
there now they only became viable like
last week additionally if they did know
about them why not go to where they were
created on earth first before all this
happened
also the odds of these you d tired guy
is coincidentally running into our gang
as they found a Dragonball with the help
of a dragon radar is astronomical the
person that was looking for the ball
seems to be this witch doctor that uses
a whip to turn people into dolls so that
he can sacrifice them to this creature
called lute however once the witch
doctor receives the Dragon Ball from the
unitards he spools them for not getting
the other dragon ball that the gang had
holed up how does this guy know where
the Dragon Balls are now if he knows
where they are then why were the bad
guys searching around the universe for
them blind it might sound like I'm
skipping over a ton of stuff here I'm
sure a lot of you are saying what no
there must be more to this than just
that I'm sorry there's really not I'm
doing my best to glaze over what isn't
necessary and to focus on the main plot
points as they stagger into my field of
view here for instance do you want me to
go in depth with this episode and
explain how the unitards go back to the
worm ball and control the gang with
dancing for literally minutes and
minutes of screen time
[Music]
no and neither do I because this is the
worst episode of Dragon Ball I've ever
seen the episode ends with pan getting
in trouble
shocking accidentally trying to fly the
unitard spaceship to Lutz planet
why because plot needs to happen episode
11 long story short pan gets captured /
turned into a Dalek glass with a long
story
he'll finds the guys and they come to
rescue her a giant robot line is
introduced and in seconds is destroyed
beikoku
where did it come from it doesn't matter
the explosion sub wipes out the witch
doctor guy holding the whip but wait the
whip is alive and turns into a golden
whip warrior thing
episode 12 so were introduced to the
real boss now I guess and it's this
weird alien guy with a soccer mom
haircut fawning over doll pants so
delicately pretty convenient isn't it
how he decided to hang on to pan instead
of throwing her into the pot like he did
with the rest of the other worshippers
the weird alien with the soccer mom
haircut begins undressing doll pan and
makes this face I think this is the
worst thing I've seen in a very long
time now if you were to ask me why is he
doing one of this why does he want to
resurrect loot I literally could not
tell you but loot is finally activated
episode 13 Adam looking pale green alien
robot baby reveals itself and its lewd
in all of his glory why does it have a
flabby chest with nipples no idea and it
turns out the soccer mom haircut wearing
alien otaku guy isn't the real boss
either this guy dr. Mewis I gotta say
this now if there have been like 30
different boss reveals first the person
that stole the ball then the leader of
his group then the witch doctor then the
whip then the whip turned into a golden
monster then the weird doll otaku guy
with the soccer mom haircut and now dr.
mu this is incomprehensible bad so it
turns out lewd is being controlled by
this dr. mu someone that looks like an
unlockable reskin of dr. Jerome
Dragonball fighters in the end the ue
tires come back and start dancing again
the fight between lewd and the team of
goku and Trunks is boring and ultimately
pan and the weird alien guy get absorbed
by loot and believe it or not I actually
remember this part from when I was a kid
pan and Goku need to coordinate their
attack to the same area one shot from
the inside and one from the outside and
if my memory serves me right it's pretty
dumb yep and it sure is the peripera
unit ads who have all been absorbed by
luo too can conveniently communicate via
telepathy to goku on the outside I hate
this show I really hate this show can I
stop eventually they hit lude right in
the sweet spot at the exact same time to
defeat him while this was happening lude
was just standing there not defending
himself waiting to be attacked by Goku
it's at this point in the story I
realized they've only retrieves two
Dragon Balls and I feel a tremendous
sadness
the button the following two remaining
episodes are essentially filler or set
up for the later antics in the next arc
episode 50 and covers the guy is landing
on a desert planet with and getting into
trouble being saved by Gil which as it
happens is my favorite episode from this
arc it's got nothing to do with the
awful main plot it's self-contained it
sets up the conflict between pan and
Gale early and despite pan treating Gil
horribly he still goes out to safer
crazy to think that the most resonant
heroic moment from the series so far for
me has been through a tiny plot device
MacGuffin robot episode 16 on the other
hand the final episode in this hour
covers the gang landing on Gil's home
planet as he seemingly betrays them Goku
and trunks get captured for a change and
pan is then left alone and that
concludes the Black Star Dragon Ball
saga what a mess of the 16 episodes that
made up the story I could easily see it
streamlined down to 10 episodes if you
remove the episodes with unrelated
material but even saying that the main
plotline seemed to me at least confused
and ultimately it lacked direction On
June of 2005 producer kozo Morishita had
an interview where he discussed the
production of Dragon Ball GT in an
effort to retain the golden timeslot of
7 p.m. every Wednesday the Brass behind
Dragon Ball decided to create a new
series in GT that would cover the
exploits of the next generation in pan
and trunks this was part of the
reasoning for changing goku to a kid to
keep him in theme with the younger
generation Dragon Ball GT itself wanted
to bring Dragon Ball back to its roots
with an adventure centric storyline and
they definitely did that here however
Dragon Ball didn't just decide to go
from light-hearted adventure centric
storytelling to galactic wide battles
with world-ending stakes in literally
one episode
Dragon Ball gradually over the course of
a decade developed and advanced the
story to naturally assume the stakes it
did GT currently as it stands already
suffers from a lot of issues and groin
pains were not something they needed on
top of this laundry list of defects and
the production issues and lack of
confidence in the product can be felt in
this quote taken straight from that
interview itself initially we made about
26 episodes worth of rough plot outlines
but around when the final script for
episode three was finished we
these travel episodes aren't going to be
interesting no matter how long we keep
them going are they and so we stopped
that's why Gil in the spaceship stopped
appearing Midway's through it's clear
from just watching it that it had no
idea of what it wanted to be one second
they're doing wacky adventures
throughout space for kids and another
second they're doing big battles
followed by more tone-deaf slapstick
with creepy undertones it's all over the
place and I'm really not a fan of it the
entire story is filled with scenarios
where I can see the writer in various
circumstances writing themselves out of
a corner whether it be through pan
getting into specific kinds of trouble
to influence the main cast into
dangerous situations the bad guys
randomly deciding not to do away with
pan as a doll that catch fish monster
having earthquakes with perfect comedic
timing or the unitards knowing telepathy
without which the situation would be
entirely lost
additionally the writing is extremely
formulaic and lazy in that very same
interview Morishita said pans rule was
to be strong but still lose to the
enemies and then be rescued by Goku a
heroine who makes Goku a hero Dragon
Ball GT has an episode where pan has
turned into a doll but that episode
established the pattern of pan sets the
incident in motion while goku resolves
it and that's Dragon Ball GT in a
nutshell extremely contrived formulaic
predictable and demonstrably
unforgivably relentlessly boring but
let's not get ahead of ourselves here
this is still only one part of a bigger
four-part picture in the next episodes I
will be covering the remaining seasons
of Dragon Ball GT as it spiraled into
consolation and obscurity how did this
happen
was it as bad as people claim today or
was it overblown and it actually had its
merits only one way to find out and I'm
happy to bear that cross if you enjoyed
this video subscribe and leave a like it
really makes a massive difference thank
you for taking the time on your day to
watch this video and I'll see you all
next week thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you